hello and welcome to this video and mr.
williger's and what are you playing I
don't even know what he's playing its
kind of this is a new trial either i
tried actually recently I you play some
some Bishop g5 stuff I remember now what
am i doing against this Queen a5 was the
thing I had a good position with this I
remember but to SS quite often screw it
up tick can take care right he repeats
the same thing and he had a pretty bad
position background anyway I see no
reason to do anything else this move I
didn't play last time i think if i
remember correctly that was the
improvement but as i said i'm not one
hundred percent sure how it's how it
actually was anyway
yeah that's pretty comfortable here try
to make sure to not get super low on
time I try at least night coming to see
5 or a 5b seven these kind of things
would be good I mean here you might play
c5 button we'll see i have night be 3 as
well as a potential idea Queen to c5 is
also an option if he allows it just ok
ok so now let's focus on that let's
focus and see that I win this game I
mean jack you really played this
absolutely badly sitting on this passive
position now so on it seemed
now canine creature c5 not sure about it
he was bad I could reroute this Bishop
to c6 that could be an idea i'm not
totally sure about the plans IAM it
feels like a decent idea and I'm hair on
the clock he wants to go clean be one I
think I can go to a kanga which is sex
that's not it's not really all that
dangerous he also has to watch out for
potential captures on f3 okay I'm just
covering this maybe I should have taken
actually this is I said okay now i'm
taking Queen d2 26 this kind of invasion
looks looks very natural
I want to put the bishop on d5 I see let
us make quite some sense ok I can take
it but I don't want to so let's let's
let's look at this Queen d7 is also an
option ok he might take on b6
i'm unsure him what can I can i play for
one attack or something I'd probably not
my rook could be cut off hmm it isn't
all that easy and Morgan okay I have an
idea though you want to put rook be
three before and win this porn I'd seem
28 is this idea okay
and he wants to play look there it's
interesting but ok this is just here and
I'm going to age 6 I mean am I losing
this or something I don't see it I mean
I haven't played it well i'm pretty
pretty sure about it because he was
basically dead already strategically but
that seemed let's see what happens
Bishop g8 Queen f7 is that what he wants
to do maybe
so Bishop should take screen shakes wow
you might have some kind of weird chick
made actually so here I can take F to
Queen age too it's not a maid though
unfortunately looks pretty awful
93 what is he doing then take with the
record anyway let's do it
time warning I don't don't see how to
win this here isn't there something Jack
hey I'll take this first
55 I go 94 oh I didn't see that move at
all I cannot go now he's got queen of a
checkmate I god damn it he found a good
move him I don't have a reply to that
now that he defended very well I mean
this position was totally resigned
totally rotten okay Queen c7 seems to
not lose him I didn't see it it seems
computer says just equal anyway now I
have to I mean he's totally outplayed
him that this position is just
strategically so atrocious I should just
win it and I didn't which is really
awful I mean this is really awful Bishop
d7 wins a pawn gesture but okay I mean I
was trying to be quick about it and I
think that was kind of reasonable he
still still drag this position but I
have to have to improve somewhere here
so how could I have killed him because
it's it's absolutely clear that this was
possible Queen D 650 593 I I couldn't
quite bring myself to play it because it
the h's look so dues you know the engine
is very clear that rook a 2 has to be
played okay and if this has to be played
this is of course fantastic because I
win any endgame here with this bone
structure this is the engines line and
it wins very easily okay then this was
the thing I couldn't bring myself to
play this move but maybe maybe this is
the thing I should have calculated this
just just try to write after had time to
do it
now this is unprotected but it cannot
attack it and they cannot just play this
I just had to take here and this is a
direct threat so this was the wind when
quite clearly but I don't believe this
is bad I mean it just cannot be it's
impossible Queen f8 is the engine Smoove
ok Trading Queens losses for white so he
has to go back and then this is what the
engine wants to do still winning yeah in
his struck chure is so bad but this is
now getting very very very difficult
this this and now f5 given by the comp
yeah this was interesting and Chinese
takes and this is say I didn't see what
you want I mean ok it seems to Serbia
drawed aah i didn't cop1 I had this idea
that something like that I would that
wins but i did not see a rook to d1 so f
five instead it's still pretty good it's
still pretty good
I could have join that but chat lead
want to draw here and this is actually
winning a while I was just thinking it's
drawn check even this can be played with
the win yeah okay there were some some
wins but I couldn't I couldn't do it I
don't know what it is sometimes it's a
real chain because well he just repeats
a totally bad line and this time I
improve on it you cannot play like that
like double against your own porn and
stuff it really should be punished and
this is what hurts ready and also
against him but anyway yeah okay thanks
for watching guys